plus on déjà dit et jean luc mélenchon
en premier qu'il serait le premier des
opposants et vous avez entendu peut-être
cette phrase maintenant qui est à ses
lèvres sur les réseaux sociaux notamment
de jean luc mélenchon à propos de cette
ville annick et votre confrère notamment
un nouveau député
le matin comme il l'appelle qui n'a
jamais connu que le contrat de travail
qu'est ce que ça que ça dit du débat
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de stéréotypes et caricatures
voire de préjugés de biais cognitifs a
travaillé chez jean luc mélenchon pour
réduire et cédric villani aux matheux
qui par ailleurs connaît
particulièrement bien les contres
travail pour avoir dirigé un institut et
pour en avoir géré quelques-uns mais
pour vous c'est une forme de mépris de
dire ça le matin comme ça ça vous un
instant vous savez je pense que c'est
plutôt une forme d'angoise jean luc
mélenchon se retrouve face à des profils
qu'il ne connaît pas des gens qu'il n'a
pas su faire monter manifestement au
sein de son parti des gens qui les
français font confiance des gens de
qualité d' expertise de talent il ne
sait pas comment ils les aborder il est
réduit à ce qui l'effraie